Dear kitten, since I have hissed at you the customary 437 times,...
...it is now my duty as the head of the household to begrudgingly welcome you.
Perhaps you are here to replace me...
...but I must do my duty and educate you on your new surroundings...
...as Maximillian once did for me, rest in peace.
Dear kitten, you should be aware that there are two kinds of food.
The first is sort of a dehydrated brown nibblet.
I think they give us these because they are training us to be astronauts.
Just a guess.
The second kind is wet food.
It is so special they keep it in little armored metal casings that no claw can penetrate.
Dear kitten, I should warn you of the monster known as Vacuum.
It can eat and yell at the same time.
To hide from Vacuum, you may use the curtains of invisibility.
Oh yeah, you're good.
Good hiding.
Oh boy.
Dear kitten, one final note.
Once in a while, you might see a little red dot.
I'm going to tell you this right now:...
...it is real and it can be caught.
I did it once.
I held it for a full minute.
But when I lifted my paws, it was gone.
So kitten, welcome to the household.
You'll do just fine.